sie schweigt sind
sie war aus
bis die ganze bande
am 4
zwei feldforscher unterwegs im
aufregenden vorstadt besucher nehmen uns
mit auf eine kleine entdeckungsreise in
den schweizer durchschnitt
das einfamilienhäuschen viertel eine
industriebrache alte dorf resten eine
blog siedlungs- allee die beiden städte
sind während eines jahres hier
eingetaucht und erzählen davon in ihrem
buch digital home 2
für die halbe schweiz ist diablo das
daheim um sie zu erfassen muss man sie
von innen her begreifen menschen leben
in raumplanungsgesetzes debatten bringen
schauen was ist wie es ist
verschiedene art ist es hat ganz nah
beieinander platz das verspricht auch
freiheiten das neutralisiert hinter dem
zug oder im auto auf der autobahn
einfach durch die orte prescht dann habe
ich die idee heraus für betoniert und es
gerade rettung versprachen die neuen
siedlungen einst mit der
industrialisierung wurde der platz in
den städten zu knapp für menschen und
fabriken arbeitersiedlungen und garten
stadtquartiere entstanden im umland der
kernstädte menschen der zweite große
schub der veräußerung auch hüsli pest
genannt brachte die mobilisierung
arbeiten in der stadt und wohnen auf dem
land zusammen mit dem
bevölkerungswachstum war der verkehr
motor der zersiedlung und ist es bis
heute geblieben
die bevölkerung wächst der boden wird
knapper die vororte verdichten werden
größer städtischer selbstbewusster nicht
zwingend schöner dass sie das hässlich
findet die spezies mensch so die
erkenntnis der autoren ist pragmatisch
jammert nicht sachliche überlegungen und
allem voran die sehnsucht nach dem
grünen haben ihn aus der stadt getrieben
in gut erschlossene stadtnähe hier in
den vororten treibt er wurzeln beatrice
stäbler zum beispiel
irgendwie hatte sie nach uster
verschlagen
heute engagiert sie sich
leidenschaftlich für ein lokales
kulturprojekt oster 1 prozent mustafa
schüler haben einen statistisch
ausgeklügelten querschnitt der
bevölkerung persönlich befragt und
porträtiert das ergebnis 333 porträts
wird nun in der örtlichen landi halle
ausgestellt wenn mitmenschen bistums
machen die kraft investieren deshalb ist
lebendig alte wird denn ich nord mit la
poste ein gesicht geben
eine vor ort statt will selber strahlen
kein stadt anhängsel sein das hat
zukunft sagen auch unsere autoren
bestehende kunst hat sich niemand
ernsthaft überlegt wie so dass man
sowohl eine institution nach schlieren
verlage ist das haltet das starke
oderstadt ganze ist doch sehr die
karierten
die städte und ihr lebendiges drumherum
werden gemeinsam zur stadt des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts behaupten
die forscher und stürzen sich wagemutig
ins nächste abenteuer